Men do. Loyalty as the ability to act however they want
and it won't affect your relationship with.
And that is why when you enter these traditional relationships
and you sign up for giving all of your decision making,
financial abilities,
financial growth,
personal growth,
you give all of that up to your husband
because he's the leader of your home.
He makes all the decisions.
You're gonna sit back and have kids
and just take care of the home and the children.
When he feels you're not being loyal enough by not cleaning enough,
they. He can always keep raising the bar
because he's the one that creates the bar.
He's the leader of the home.
So if the bar keeps raising,
it's you that needs to keep rising, honey.
And what's wrong with you?
Are you not loyal enough?
Are you not good enough?
Are you not strong enough?
Because the other women are doing it.
My friends at work are telling me how happy they are.
Why are you such a failure?
Entering a traditional marriage that
that adheres to traditional gender roles
is setting yourself up to be someone's personal,
living domestic servant.
And they can and will create any reason to end it
when they feel like it
because they have all the power.
Be mindful. Watch yourself entering that relationship.